Okay, Lemma, zuerst möchte ich Glückwünsche sagen.
Ja, du rockst, Lana, nette
Persönlichkeit.
Alexander Reebok ist der Gewinner des letzten Jahres.
Du kennst den Russen. Ich
frage mich, wann er zu dir gekommen ist, und
jeder in Norwegen fragt sich, ob
das wahr ist oder nicht
und dann sagte er, küss mich hier und dann,
als du langsam kamst, tat er das und
dann, oh, zu Überraschung berühren deine
Lippen jetzt seine Lippen
nicht
hey yo Ich glaube nur, ich kann diese Frage nicht beantworten
, ob es mir gefallen hat oder nicht
, das war eine Sache, die passiert ist, und ja, es
war nichts Besonderes, denke ich, aber ich mag
euch, Leute, ihr seid lustig